[Music]
demi lovato has come a long way she's
now over ninety day sober and looking
happy and healthy since her apparent
drug overdose yeah it looks like a
complete 180 and it's such a relief to
see her looking so great
I know her fans are happy and so are we
I know hey guys I'm Courtney teza know
and I'm Hallie Steven okay so et can't
confirm Jamie was spotted out of rehab
for the first time over the weekend an
eyewitness tells us the popstar looked
happy and comfortable at Halloween
Horror Nights on Friday apparently she
wasn't approached and everyone just kind
of let her be which is good and yeah
good let her do her but it's her dinner
date at Matsuhisa restaurant with
clothing designer Henry Levy that has
everyone buzzing oh yeah so there's some
new pics out guys Demi is seen holding
hands with Henry and of course that
sparks some romance rumors people are
now thinking this is her new man but we
want to give you a bit of a backstory on
Henry so he is the founder of a clothing
label and he has also battled with
addiction at a young age and he told
complex in 2016 quote I was like a up in
high school and did his first stint in
rehab at fifteen at visions adolescent
treatment a Malibu facility for
underaged addicts okay so what's the big
deal here is he's also an addict with
Demi and of course it's a really sticky
subject but we're really concerned if
she's jumping too soon into a
relationship what are your thoughts how
well you know recovery experts say that
you should spend a year out of recovery
before you get involved with anyone
romantically so just as someone who
loves Demi and wants the best for her I
think I'm a little worried to see her
out holding hands with somebody
absolutely but since he is a clothing
designer instance you know he is an
addict I feel like this could also just
be a friendship and maybe people are
blowing it out of proportion since it's
a photo of them holding hands I mean
when you're talking about you're a
history like that I would imagine that
you can have a warm embrace and and not
mean something
romantic absolutely there's always this
big thing when stars are hanging out we
automatically link them together as an
item I feel like they could be mapping
out her first outfit for her public
appearance there's so many option
totally and I bet she's gonna look so
chic when that day comes all right lor
they could be bonding because they have
similar trauma they both in and rehab
I'm know you guys let us know if you
think that they're friends or if they're
our future lovers let us know in the
comments below we want to hear all your
thoughts okay let's move on so last
month
Timmy's mom Diana gave us a positive
update on how Demi's doing that's how we
found out she's 90 days sober but she
also relived the traumatic day that her
daughter overdosed take a look I knew
that she wasn't sober but let me clarify
I didn't know what she was doing because
she doesn't live with me she's 26
you know um so I just knew that she
wasn't sober and that's all I really
knew at that time you know I I loved
seeing dummies mom I think that they
have such a strong bond and I can only
imagine what her family is going through
absolutely you have to have family and
good friends surrounding you when you're
dealing with something like this and as
we know timmy has had a long history of
addiction back in 2017 there was a
documentary she made called simply
complicated where she admitted that she
did cocaine at the age of 17 and then in
2010 she entered a treatment center
because she self-harmed and had eating
issues and in 2013 she checked into a
sober house but this recent relapse
really shocked her fans because in March
she celebrated six years sober she
tweeted so grateful for another year of
joy health and happiness
it is possible yes it is yes if it is
and it still is and in June she released
that song sober where she admitted she
wasn't sober anymore and a source at the
time told et that she relapsed some time
between the beginning of April and the
end of May between the North American
and European leg of her world tour and
then of course we know in July she was
transported to an LA Hospital for an
apparent drug overdose exactly so she
has this long history with her drug
addiction but we have so much hope for
Dimmie that she's gonna come out of this
I mean 90 days sober is a huge
accomplishment for someone who has had
that history but we want to know what
you guys are thinking about those
pictures that surface are people reading
into these pics of Demi holding hands
with the new man
could it be new love or do we think Demi
is leaning on her friends who know
firsthand how hard addiction can be and
we want to know if you guys think Demi
should spend a little more time out of
the spotlight to heal let us know and
let's leave her some messages of love
and encouragement oh yeah let's keep it
positive and let's keep that
conversation going
until next time we've got you guys
covered for your pop culture fix